[Musik]
ok jetzt dreht sie komplett am rad
familie das sind menschen die in unser
aller leben eine sehr wichtige rolle
spielen man hält zusammen man stets ein
andermal achtet aufeinander und man
spannt sich gegenseitig den freund aus
und dementsprechend sehr gut dass die
bildungsanstalt nummer eins für
deutschlands jugend namentlich die
rtl-2-sendung hilft hierbei eine folge
gemacht hat wie schauen sie heute an
bilden und zweiter und bis zum nächsten
mal ganz genau was wir machen müssen
wenn die eigene schwester mal wieder den
eigenen freund ausstand
ok also ja das entscheiden bei unsere
beiden schwestern hier auf der linken
seite die linke sieht aus als hätte sie
eine ausbildung zur buchhalterin gemacht
und würde den ganzen tag nicht aus dem
haus gehen die rechte dagegen sieht aus
wie keine ahnung wieso eine superheldin
aus irgend einem zeichentrickfilm also
soweit alles ganz normal
[Musik]
ja macht sind auf jeden fall also die
sitzen hier zwei meter von dem typen
entfernt über den sie reden und
beratschlagen sich einfach auf normaler
zimmerlautstärke was sie mit ihm machen
wollen nicht unbedingt die klügste
entscheidung
[Musik]
was soll der beruf jetzt bringen
also leute ich bin keine frau ich kenne
mich jetzt mit den geheimen signalen
nicht so genau aus aber was bedeutet es
dass man sich ein glas in den ausschnitt
steckt hat das irgend eine tiefergehende
botschaft ja wahrscheinlich ist sie ihre
schwester alter wie vergleicht also den
auto und so die linke hat sohnes recht
blasse die rechte ist schon relativ
brown dazu hat ja ein halt schwarz rote
haare
fehlt nur dass die sich so ein katana
aus der hüfte zieht und dann mit so
einem riesigen schwert haben wir die
ganze war kurz und kleine akt das würde
passen zu ihr aber ganz ehrlich man kann
sich entschieden nicht von übel
ich wäre auch schockiert man man steht
ja so an seiner wahl trinkt sein getränk
auf einmal spricht von der seite seine
frau anleger aber denkst wirklich
komplett vorbei alter hat ein fucking
leeres getränke glas ausschnitt und hat
einfach schwarz-rote dreadlocks
sorry es nicht was billig und billig
funktioniert es gut und er weiß auch ich
habe jetzt auch im glashaus schnitt 36
was billig ich bin nicht billig ist ein
fucking glas immer raus wenn man das ich
bin high class ich sags ja leute die das
ist keine normale frau das ist irgendwie
so eine superheldin oder irgend so eine
anti helden aus irgendeinem mann gar
safe co sie hatten allerdings auch
gesagt er wird freundlich sagen was
passieren wird für die kommt gleich aus
dem nebenzimmer wieder so 242 katarers
in der hand ich dachte ich muss mal die
gelegenheit und warte hat ist das auch
schon wieder für eine szene alter es ist
kein mensch wieder dieser bar kann rtl 2
wird immer anfangen diese statisten zu
bezahlen das hat zumindest so die
drehorte bisschen gefüllt sind ganz
ehrlich ich dachte vielleicht könnten
sie mal was trinken gehen nur wie beides
oben detail gestresster weil die anmache
grad war ja wohl eine absolute
nullnummer oder nicht
oder dann förster
wie ohne ihre schwester tiger du hast es
immer noch nicht verstanden was für
billig man das ist high class guck dir
macht machten vergleich leute okay aber
ohne so das ist jetzt wirklich billig
hier einfach ich bin billiger mensch
einfach okay achtung jetzt noch fragen
instant high society hochwertiger
gebildeter mensch ja dies nicht so
entspannt habe so verhält sich ein
mensch der gerade so in einem
selbstverteidigungskurs ist nicht
anfassen
sonst muss ich dir dein handgelenk auf
den rücken drehen in spanisch
ich mache den vorschlag
ok also scheinbar ich dass die story
also wir haben diese brave schwester
oder links die jetzt warum auch immer
mit diesen tätowierten typen auf der
rechten seite zusammenkommt haben und da
kommt dann wieder unsere manga sofort
ins spiel und will jetzt der braven
hinaus sparen
also ganz ehrlich wenn die den den glas
trinkt noch mal anwendet dann dann hat
die blonde verloren
danke du wirst es nicht bereuen ich
verspreche mir gesagt dieses cluster
drinnen alter ist doch mal raus also
immer mehr als heute jetzt genug zeit
über die toilette war keine ahnung 20
minuten nicht im bild dann hättest du
schon mal rausnehmen können kleinere
aber okay heute erreicht haben wir sehen
wir hier zusammenkommen dass beide
schwestern dem interesse haben aber wir
müssen jetzt mal zudem news.com wo ihre
schwester tatsächlich versucht jetzt
jeden freund auszuspannen
okay okay da gibt es also der vater von
diesen beiden mädels hat jetzt diesen
typen eingeladen zum essen und unsere
hoch geschätzte schwertkämpferin hier
hat jetzt den plan
scheinbar beim abendessen dann den
freund ihrer schwester irgendwie keine
ahnung um finger zu wickeln
der vater empfängt zum ersten mal den
noch nicht noch nicht freund und seiner
tochter zeigt ihm so ein fotoalbum in
dem kinder sind und so jung uns kann es
mir auch machen
ok egal was ist mit diesem vaterlos der
ist ja geisteskrank
der noch nicht freut das muss ich
betonen dennoch nicht freund seiner
eigenen tochter ist zu besuch er sagt
ihm direkt mallorca ein kind mit der und
dann sagt ja übrigens einst mit der ein
schwester nicht gehabt da ist ja noch
eine andere menschen abstoßend
ich habe gesagt dass ich auch die still
was war das denn jetzt
was soll man dazu noch sagen leute es
ist einfach einfach geschwisterliebe das
ist das was den zusammenhalt in der
familie ausmacht dass auf jeden fall
geschwister um die gleiche person
konkurrieren keinerlei rücksicht
aufeinander nehmen wir beide die ist
wirklich dies komplett los diese frau
silvia anders sein los mit dir lass den
scheiß nein
ok jetzt dreht sie komplett am rad ganz
so ernst heute ich glaube bisschen eine
sehr gute beschreibung dieser person bei
also dann wenn man jetzt mal ernst
nehmen würde war darüber nachdenkt wie
sehr kann man auf die eigene schwester
heißen dass man sowas abzieht
da wirst du bereuen oscar sowie spinnst
du was wird das jetzt sagt sie wieder es
bereuen aber wieso wird es bereut also
was machst du denn packst du endlich mal
eine die kattas aus oder das halt auch
immer wieder das gleiche
vor nicht allzu langer zeit hatten wir
eine hilfen erfolge wo die freundin der
anderen freunde in den typ ausspannen
wollte hier sind jetzt schwestern aber
die story ist einfach eins zu eins
leicht
aber man kann es verstehen leute sich
eine neue story für eine neue hilfe
folge auszudenken ist es wäre auch zu
viel aufwand das kann doch keiner
verlangen komplett los okay gut dann
ging es ihr wohl an der stelle zu
schnell ganz kurze frage am rande noch
mal eine hilf mir ratgeberserie welcher
wächterrat wurde mir jetzt gegeben oder
euch gegeben dass man sich ein glas in
den ausschnitt stecken sollte ist es das
ja perfekt leute aber wieder einiges
dazugelernt an der stelle noch mal
vielen dank an die ratgeberserie hilft
mir
es war wieder sehr wertvoll für weitere
wertvolle ratschläge habe ich euch hier
drüben ein für euch vorgeschlagen das
video verlinkt das war zwar deutlich
kürzeren
bis zum nächsten mal